[Musique]
après une saison 2018 2019 a réussi les
féminines du chesnay versailles font
leur retour en nationale 2 une nouvelle
étape des nouveaux défis pour les
joueuses emmenées par leur coach vinko
bardy qu on va continuer notre travail
de l'année dernière on va se baser sur
notre défense et on va essayer de jouer
avec beaucoup de contre attaques comme
on vient de monter de nationale 3 une
nouvelle équipe avec trois nouvelles
choses
il faut qu'elle s'adapte le maintien
c'est notre objectif
durant l'intersaison trois départs à
noter comblé par l'arrivée de trois
recrues et dites nobles et si l'
international équatorienne arrivée d'une
université canadienne
mathilde marchèrent en provenance de
palaiseau et laurine kerboeuf qui évolue
en nationale une la saison dernière avec
l'équipe de saut mettre du rythme et
l'intensité en défense
donc c'est vraiment sympa on prend du
plaisir contestable c'est plus intensif
en nationale 2 parce que généralement
nationale 3 les personnes qui jouent
sont un peu plus âgés donc un peu moins
et un peu moins d'énergie sur le terrain
de france et surtout ça et puis même la
façon dont j'allais faire la façon de
réfléchir dans le jeu
en nationale 2 commencement la capitaine
arrache dana radio nowitzki a déjà foulé
les parquets de nationale 2 avec le
chesnay versailles avec une reprise au
mois d'août elle est satisfaite de la
préparation de l'équipe
elles sont arrivées bien préparait déjà
et au fur et à mesure avec les
entraînements on a monté notre forme et
je passe pour l'instant pour commencer
le championnat on est prêtes on n'est
pas encore à 100% mais et je pense que
les filles aussi et ce auprès de jeunes
joueurs nationale 2 et 2 de se maintenir
pour commencer après on verra
rendez vous ce samedi 21 septembre pour
cette première à domicile de la saison
c'est à 20 heures au gymnase du bel air
aux chaînés rocancourt